morning Millennials good morning is a
way of life as you know it's not it's
not lies oh wow we're gonna get right
into it just say he said you said
immediately that I sit on that throne of
lies it's not it's not lies it's not
lies you sit on a throne of Quito season
I sit on a throne of ketosis and you sit
on a throne of keto merch know what you
toasty keto Marilla merch I'm wearing a
Chanel banette barrette right now so I'm
not gonna Wow you in a pink hat it's a
nice yes I think it okay I didn't really
I can't really tell it'll look really
cute on me I think you should stick with
the black rocker vibe but then if folks
wanted to get some of this merch where
could they find it they would go to Kido
season dot-com very easy I'm so shocked
that nobody had that domain I'm just
like right chops and I'm shocked that
you know like a toaster didn't get like
secured for you and then you had to get
it from that totally was just there
$2.99
thanks GoDaddy great well we're so happy
you're here and this is the end of a
very long Jackie O takeover week filled
with many different personalities voices
and opinions and me hunkering down as
your loyal host so anyways a show comes
as a nice you know end of the week treat
a low-key what a treat I am a keto
friendly treat the dog treat we're just
gonna shoot the [ __ ] give you the news
you need to know honestly it's not that
crazy out there today but there are some
interesting business stories that I
thought we could talk about considering
we're here with a businessman mm-hmm
cool what are we talking about we're
talking about a lot of stuff we'll get
to it how are you I'm great
thriving enjoying life are you missing
your wife more than anything but Theo
has really been a very very good
replacement he started sleeping in her
spots I have to tell you something about
Theo I have a theory about him I think
he is unbelievably depressed what yeah
why he's just like these days whenever
snitch and I come around like oh yeah no
that makes sense when I pick you guys
torture when I picked him up the other
day he was crying for me he was crying
for snitching like yeah he loves us but
like we're just his ads he should only
be crying for his parents and his just
his spirit just hasn't
in there's there's definitely a change
when Claudia goes away for a week and
she spends the day with him that's
something that he's definitely missing
he's definitely missing his mother he's
definitely missing his mother and I
think it's time she came home for him
I agree the hell's she doing out there
actually I heard she had a great show
last night in Brea I heard that from the
toasters I heard it from her it just
seemed like everyone had a great time
and I had a migraine and her she killed
it on a daily pop is incredible it was
incredible out we haven't been on the
show since she was under pop and
honestly I got featured so much I felt
like I was on daily pop I was like wow I
did a great job
they chose two pictures of both of us
and they are a premium pictures from you
know recent weight loss wedding season
Akito season times
where's Access Hollywood just was like
the fatter the better I'm you know I'm
beggars can't be choosers I was totally
running and you know I should be I just
got so many shout outs like that I'm the
carissa which we've we've discussed on
the show that I am which is why like I
respect Krista and her craft mm-hmm
and it was just so great and it's it's
really great when you're watching your
favorite show because daily pop is one
is the only other morning show i watch
and your favorite person is on it mm-hmm
it's crazy when that happens is crazy I
know I just love Haylie Duff right I'm
sorry
Hillary 9 I get that like we don't we
don't offend we don't hear from Jennifer
Lopez's sister and she's a new end we
don't hear from I don't know name
another star that has a sister that I've
never heard of honestly a lot of people
no one is as good as Hilary Duff in
giving her sister a career but a lot of
celebrities to do that you know look at
Mark Wahlberg yeah no it doesn't his
brothers are brothers they're both
famous not one who rode the others
coattails know like Haylie Duff what
does she do like why is she on daily pop
oh well they if she was a guest host
yesterday that cuz like Morgan who's the
third host has been out a lot because
she does another show now and she can't
do it she can't film on Thursdays
Fridays and Mondays cuz she does nightly
pop um so they have a guest host three
games I was wondering where Morgan is
yeah she's only there on Tuesday
Wednesdays now we're Instagram friends
she's cool she is she's really cool
she's nice lady
but back to uh Haylie Duff just because
I'm I'm very very curious is she an
actress does she have like a nice social
feed like I know she starred in the
award-winning movie material girls with
her sister where they took down a really
a big cosmetics company that was acting
illegal practices and it was it was huge
so she's an activist she's an activist
she's an activist after she does
activism through her acting okay and I
think the residuals from that movie
naked so she never has to work again
oh is that a popular movie I never even
saw a movie you're missing out and I've
seen a lot of Hilary Duff movies you're
missing out and just she was my girl and
you know the plot of which should not be
confused with the movie from Prada to
nada
which is the exact same film just with a
different actors camilla belle because
she's only famous for what she does on
the mattress Oh Taylor Swift Oh God it
all comes back to Taylor Swift my god
that is a terrible call it's a terrible
line from a very mean song oh my god
yeah that was when they were Swift said
Heller said she's an actress but she's
better number what she does on the
mattress Ryan and I straight was a
mattress like a savage I was associated
yeah it was all I didn't know that you
had that in her Bobby it wasn't her
finest moment Wow anyways apparently
Haylie Duff is a Hallmark star oh great
she doesn't belong on that show jealous
isn't belong on that show I'm daily pop
yeah I thought she actually held it down
though she did a good job I didn't know
what to expect because honestly hosting
is it's not so easy everyone um but I
thought she came very prepared like she
clearly did her research and her
homework she took it seriously which is
all you can ask for people but then of
course she got out shown unfortunately
by Claudia ray I only saw the clip that
Claudia sent me which was mostly Claudia
yes so I didn't get to hear really speak
so I just assumed that she like sat like
the whole time just like like oh like
this is the Claudia show and I'm just
gonna sit here being Hilary's sister and
it was the Claudia segment and she was
gonna sit there being Hilary's it was it
was the Claudia segment of the show Oh
coastal show she's a co-host yes she's
filled in for Morgan oh so there's there
are three hosts of the
yes Wow try host yeah maybe I should
slide right in here
oh yeah host think what would you bring
to the table that's not already at the
table I don't know some male charisma ha
ha that's funny
oh ok anyways well she just says it all
she'll be back on Monday but until then
I think you know a little one gents
lunch takeover never hurt nobody
one chance well what do you want to show
while you're here buns I did that oh we
can do that again you can keep doing it
should we sing about it
ketose oh wait i was trying to figure
out I could do like the jg Wentworth do
you know just let me know season Keemun
Jesus is in Jesus easy.com it's pretty
good have you heard of speeches on the
garlic bread yet no for one Italian
camber was my idea so funny
sneak chest on the garlic can you do the
entire GGY mirth commercial by heart uh
no if you need a long-term payment but
you need cash now call jgu and okay he's
77 cash now if you need long-term weight
loss but you need keto now ketosis calm
Kido Kido season calm they'll help you
lose weight and put it on - they're very
confused what do if you need some weight
loss and more so friends cookie I should
also it's very true keto season is just
as fun about losing weight as it is
about gaining without being happy that's
what we need in this world happiness the
morning toast is keto season it is this
interaction is keto season it is waking
up this morning was not good not keto
season but waking up in the morning
every morning is keto season yeah thanks
to the man upstairs the part of waking
up the art of waiting of ketosis kudos
the practice is not no no I hear you
well we're gonna hit you with the fast
side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and you'll let us
know if the story's keno season or not
cool how does that sound sounds great
okay the first step is definitely not
quito season chicago demands jessie
Smollett pay 130 thousand dollars for
the cost of his investigation the city
of Chicago wants a hundred and thirty
thousand one hundred and six dollars and
15 cents in the next seven days from
actor Jesse Smollett to cover the cost
of the investigation into claims he was
attacked and what he described to police
investigators as a possible hate crime
in a letter sent to Smollett in care of
his attorneys the city's Corporation
Counsel says if smell at doesn't pay the
city might prosecute him using she could
Chicago's Municipal Code or other legal
remedies quote this city feels this is a
responsible and legally justifiable
amount to collect to help offset the
cost of the investigation city spokesman
bill McCaffrey said molest offense
seemed to not comment on the letter and
referred CNN to an earlier statement in
which they said Mayor Rahm Emanuel and
pleased superintendent Eddie Johnson
need to apologize to their client quoted
is the mayor and the police chief who
owed Jesse who owe him an apology for
dragging an innocent man's character
through the mud jesse has paid enough oh
my god who wrote that um Jesse's lawyers
know who wrote the article they oh that
was a quote this is a that was a
quotation I understand Wow Wow
not Quito season nikitos season all and
honestly while we're charging Jesse for
his time you know we took up a lot of
time on this show talking about it both
when we thought it was real and both
when we knew it was a hoax and that's
time we could have spent you know Sarah
not bad so I'd like to get an injunction
in there yep Tim I don't know for what
but yeah I want to be I want a piece I
want for time energy and like emotions
like this has been an emotional roller
coaster I remember the day when we first
reported this story it was so sad and
heartbreaking and just like I feel like
so many people in this country we're
like so demoralized that this is capable
this is possible in 2019 like this is
where we're at and it's like actually
know it maybe it wasn't as bad as that
but still we'll never know because the
charges were dropped so justice will
never be served for either Jesse for the
public for the brothers for no one this
is a case where no justice is served
like because even if he is innocent he
should like go to trial and everything
so that he can be proved innocent you
know isn't it but wasn't it made very
obvious that he's not innocent yeah but
because the charges like that no I get
it they were dropped yeah so that's it
so that's it cool I mean a lot of like
the city of Chicago is not happy about
it they're trying to you know get some
justice apparently the US Postal Service
and the FBI are still looking into him
so at a state level the charges have
been dropped but on a federal level with
mail fraud which you know it's not an
episode of morning toast if someone's
not committing mail fraud because of the
mail fraud it's a it's a federal offense
I understand maybe perhaps it's true I
didn't send his own hate mail mm-hmm
it's very messy and it's tiring to talk
about because anything could be the
truth you know yeah and we'll never know
and I think that the Chicago what it's
the PD or who's going after him yeah the
Chicago Police are pieced yeah they put
in all this hard work just for the
state's attorney to drop the charges
yeah but I read an article that they've
been taking a lot of Ellis lately
apparently they are not great at
prosecuting people weld and off and
often get it wrong is is what I read but
I have I have no facts or supporting to
like all documentaries watched it always
you know justice has never really served
look at our Kelly mm-hmm look at oje
mm-hmm
you know anyways also in related news
empire hits lowest ratings ever
following Jessie smell that scandal
Jessie some let's TV drama crash and
burn Wednesday night when three point
nine seven million viewers tuned in the
lowest ratings in the show's history
according to TVLine a day earlier smell
it told reporters that he was ready to
get back to work after Chicago
prosecutors dropped all criminal charges
against him for allegedly fabricating a
racial and homophobic attack this is
actually very shocking because I felt as
though people would tune in just to see
how Empire the show is dealing with it
just out of curiosity but it actually
seems like this is a protest it's like
even those people who are curious are
like I'm not going to give you the view
because I want you to know that I'm not
cool with what's going on yeah and I
think the show is going to have to
because they're in a lose-lose position
they can't bring Jesse back because the
people will be so upset and they can't
fire him because they have no cause yep
I thought they fired him no they wrote
him off of two episodes just while
everything was in flux but the charges
have been dropped they can't fire him he
could sue them for wrongful termination
mm-hmm should have been lawyers
everybody's suing left and right I know
I've gotta get in this I don't know I
would be like the most I would be the
anxious lawyer like practicing in the
mirror what I'm gonna say so much public
speaking goes into it I mean they do the
show so how terrible that I be but I
would just have a pin all the time
mm-hmm I would be like a Yeller actually
you might be yeah I think I'm pretty
convincing I know I can live pretty
easily I think I'm so naive you know you
are you are I think that's why it would
have been a good juror because I really
would have believed everyone as they
paid for that the case that I was up for
it it already had like a four week um
with most cases whether they're like
civil cases it'll be a few days or if
it's a criminal case you don't know but
it already had been scheduled out for
four weeks and I was like you know what
maybe I could do this like if I had to
and then it was giving me so much
insight it's like I do a [ __ ] morning
show this is literally I'm the person
who can't do your four weeks so I spoke
up and I was like only spoke up yeah and
they excuse me were they upset I think
they were just like annoyed that I
didn't speak up sooner you know yeah I
heard that you like didn't speak up
sooner and I was thinking why you
provide didn't you speak up I know
because the judge was really compelling
it they always are that's their job he
was such a great judge first of all he
made the young men gave up their seats
for the women and the elderly and I was
just like thank you because I didn't
have a seat mm-hmm and then he was
talking about how yes we are all busy
people there is a reason why any one of
us can't serve for weeks but this is
your civil service any one of us could
be in a position where we commit a crime
and we would really appreciate 12 of our
peers who are unbiased sitting on that
stand and giving us like a rough fair
chance and I was just like he spoke to
me and I was like you know what gun to
my head I couldn't miss for weeks
there's Koval's looking this week yeah
but then I realized there is no gun to
my head it would cause major
inconvenience and
anxiety and and a financial burden is
here's the problem with the jury system
if you want everyone in the world to
come in and sit there for four weeks
then you need to pay those people their
salaries for four weeks
no but they get paid their work not
every your employee that's it
I get paid through your employer has
Kate not not if you don't have a
full-time job if you don't got your free
like you if you are on a four-week trial
and you're not getting paid that is
reason why you don't have to serve know
what I'm saying
but jury duty does if you go by the way
through a part-time job jury duty pays
you 40 dollars a day that's what I'm
saying but your part-time job let's say
that you're freelance and you're making
$200 a day or whatever that is it should
be the opportunity cost of missing work
no um no because I think your employers
expect you to pay you and in the off
chance that they can't or they don't
then you don't then it's a financial
burden you don't have to serve but I
think it would be it would be so much
more complicated they started paying
people and also people would lie and
then all of a sudden to bring your tax
returns security and it's like jury duty
option jury duty is hard enough imagine
getting double pay that's exactly why
they don't do it nobody could I know
you're sitting here thinking how can I
make more money they actually think that
the way the jury duty works surprisingly
it works pretty well
mhm I thought it was very efficient the
people who were over the microphone were
like cracking jokes and like in good
spirits considering they say and do the
same things every single day and they go
for the government so like they don't
even have to be nice anywhere yep they
just need to fix that video where they
tell you to silence your beeper
like it's an old video yeah but you know
there's always a beeper in the room
really yeah I mean people have a beeper
do you know if somebody with a beeper I
don't but you know I run in the high
tech crowd mm-hmm right some people
don't run in the high tech crowd mm-hm
mm-hm
you know yeah I'll see your birthday's
coming up next Wednesday because the
invitation for your party yes um what's
the vibe how many people did you invite
oh my well don't say just if you're home
and didn't get it many people did I
invite like is it gonna be like what
what's the venue space like am I gonna
be able to sit what kind of shoes should
I wear is there this is this is a dance
party so
an open bar dance party okay alcohol
brought to you by Panora card my friends
so so you're getting excited yeah I just
like you never want to get too hyped for
your own birthday party because then
it's just gonna be a crash and burn also
27 is a rather sad age no it's just like
your your best years are behind you in
terms of your youth I disagree I think I
disagree
you think so actually for men you just
keep getting better
no but in terms of youth I'm not saying
that I'm not gonna eat gracefully I'm
just gonna keep getting better looking
and better looking every day but in
terms of youth in terms of my body
actually my body can only go up alright
so he's out 27 is gonna be a great year
27 is gonna be right here I think you're
but you'll be a good 27 I think so too
I think so too summer's almost here
isn't that crazy that is crazy by summer
I need to spring it so sad because I
gear so we came for your birthday party
but you're a man so there's really not
much you can do other than like brush
your hair and like throw on some
aftershave and maybe whiten your teeth
have you tried that do you plan on doing
that because if so have you tried candid
Co no again it is helping people gain
confidence through accessible and
affordable orthodontic Camp care Canada
makes the process of straightening your
teeth convenient and easy by having the
customer take the process into their own
hands and even though the customer is
taking the process into their own hands
candids network of highly trained
orthodontist review each and every case
and direct the entire aligner plan so it
can help you strain your teeth which is
something that some people over here
need to work on mm-hmm or I can help you
whiten your teeth which is also what
some people over here know I did I mean
everyone can go for a little bit of
pointy teeth candid co candid CO and
you're one step away from getting
straighter whiter teeth take advantage
of candids risk-free starter kit
guarantee plus when you use our
dedicated Lane candid co.com slash toast
you'll save 50% on your modeling kit
that's a deal
did someone say model that's candid
co.com slash toast you get 50% off the
price of your modeling kit candid co.com
slash toast as in the morning to this
candid CA and
I D co-ceo calm sasha TOA st i think you
should get on it never say like nothing
no shade but it's like as a man all you
have to do is have nice teeth yeah nice
shoe and a hair i want to address what
just one i want to address that
everybody every girl just think so a guy
just gets out of bed throws on a t-shirt
and looks good that's not true we also
need to worry about our skin
occasionally moisturize I have a very
dry index finger that I need to rub
moisturizer on sometimes right oh it's
crusty it's a crusty index finger
sometimes I need to take one of those
scrubs that claudia has in the bathroom
and like scrub my face also now I'm all
natural these days so I don't put in so
much stuff but I used to have to put in
stuff into my hair yeah it was a little
bit was becoming a little too much but
yeah so I resent the fact that men don't
need to put in a lot of effort we also
need to buy cool clothes okay and match
like cool stuff like these like cool
Adidas sneakers these are cool right
very cool I understand that the rest of
me is just like a black t-shirt and
jeans but right you really teach her but
you are a single father this week Obama
this week you'll see what I'm wearing
Saturday night do you have an outfit oh
no I said it was Saturday night what's
wrong with that
nothing I just supposed to be surprised
her who you're the birthday boy it's
true and everyone who's going knows when
it is true Saturday night not a nap how
do you feel about having a birthday
party technically in a different month
than your birthday wow that's trippy
it's weird it's very weird and I just I
can't believe you're dude that's that's
so like six sweet six I know like it was
only four days though are you turning 16
I wanted to do it on the 4th but that's
not possible and and I wanted to do it
it's before we planned our shindig
whatever it was impossible for other
reasons I was just giving you [ __ ] and
it's not possible on the 6th
because my lovely wife is out of town
again so we were left with this date
honestly it's a great weekend because I
like everyone's here and there were no
other plans it is it's just like you
have your birthday party in March but
your birthday's in april like i could
also hang over the summer
exactly on a boat where we going it's
good what is that on them do you
remember I lonely island of course I do
I'm on a boo they have a concert coming
up this summer up here 17 yeah what by
the way they're touring that's crazy I
mean at like ab similar should go on
tour tonight to see there's nothing
crazy like Jojo C was on tour like any
like people tour yeah but like on tour
person singing the Hanukkah song really
okay well well that would he should Adam
Sandler's should be on tour singing it
Lonely Island is on tour singing oh
great you know who should go on tour
Hannah Montana and by the way she is
alive and well I'm gonna get the belly
and I take it slow then rock out the
show you get the best of both worlds I
mix it all together
that opposes both best of both on the
record scratches I know a lot of songs
those a little awkward it's not awkward
no I can tell me a song I can sing a
song nobody let me get through a story
first and then we'll just go on a
handout riff by the way who told you had
this story Ben told me about the story
Hannah Montana is alive and well you
guys living her best life on Miley
Cyrus's Instagram stories where Miley
got a haircut and some bangs and all of
a sudden she's Hannah Montana and this
comes after weeks long of Miley posting
premium Instagram stories that have been
flashbacks and our Instagram account at
Hannah Montana is now taken and followed
by Miley Cyrus and I'm shipped to the
[ __ ] core because I don't know
if you guys know this about me I've
tried to tell you a few times but I'm
like growing up Hannah Montana was my
therapist like she was the only two she
is the reason I am Who I am and I'm
sitting here in this chair right now she
got me through everything I mean the
climb literally just like brought years
back onto my life and maybe this revamp
can take Rico back from like the weird
dark side the moisés iris
well no he's not and like he's just so
artsy
you know that's what I'm saying I think
you can bring it back to Rico Rico the
artists okay people are freaking out
about your mic or something I think
you're being like so loud I don't know
what what's the problem with snake he's
just being loud when you get passionate
cool well everybody can [ __ ] off
next time I won't come on the show loud
nuts turn your volume down I guess cuz I
don't think he's gonna do it on it's on
I'll be quiet
okay I'm gonna let's play a hannah
montana fun game and you could do
whatever you want with your voice
because there's no taming there's no
tape okay I'm gonna give you a hand
Montana song and you have to sing it
nobody's perfect
pretty good pretty good
okay I'm gonna step it up a level a
little bit and by the way please be
normal I got nerve I know that was the
course okay rock star I might even be a
actor nice
he could be the one you could be the one
hoedown throwdown
[Music]
pop it lock it polka dot it
country-fried and hit put your hockey
mask and move side salad jump to the
left stick it glad zigzag crossed the
floor shuffle in diagonal when drum hits
hands on his one foot it 180 twisting
zigzag steps lad lean it left hop three
times shake it out head to throw it all
together that's how we roll do the
hoedown throwdown do the hoedown
throwdown do the hoedown yeah that's how
we roll do you know the ice cream freeze
it's very similar to hoedown throwdown
do the ice cream breeze but no you okay
what about make some noise this is a
good one don't let anyone tell you that
you're not strong enough
don't give up there's nothing wrong with
just being yourself that's more than
enough
look at these lyrics you guys empowering
she is such a feminist icon it's so
exciting
it is Mike as my voice better I'm just
curious I I don't know I've stopped um
can I get me their usernames and I like
semi when you're playin like a flaming
pile of [ __ ] to their doorstep or
something just like like thanks for
watching and critiquing me and a little
merch and oh yeah flaming the key to
season a head on fire um anyways this is
so exciting even if it means nothing I
just love that Hanna
I'm sorry Miley who really for so long
like refused to acknowledge her alter
ego it's like
camper refusing to acknowledge the town
in Cambron that they're the same person
that she's finally embraced her and
learned and realizing goes there's
nothing wrong there was nothing ever
wrong with Hannah Montana she was an
icon she was a pop culture pioneer and
she changed so many lives including my
own like I don't know that there's
anyone out there who at any point in
their lives was a bigger Hannah Montana
fan than me it was one of my favorite
shows but looking back have you ever
googled Oliver and looked at his outfits
like recently um no but like I'm sure
you got a DUI okay like no not recent
outfits like looking at his outfit on
the show like you were these are guile
vests and like what the hell are you
doing here in Southern California
yeah it's 90 degrees and you're wearing
an argyle vest when you're 14 years old
yeah it was just like crazy no it was
crazy times also people who were like oh
people at school don't know what's at
Montana because she's wearing a wig like
they really made her they made her look
really different with just a wig but
she's really with [ __ ] with between
Miley Stewart and Hannah Montana like it
was really believable like I was like
except her face no but it was really
just the weight changed her face and
then like season three when she got like
a haircut Hannah they really were like
so ahead of the game mm-hmm it was a
great show what's your favorite Miley
Cyrus song not not recent like Hannah
Montana
each year x' miley cyrus on decline like
the climb is my favorite song of my
whole life it's just and it never gets
old to me mm-hmm and it was actually
spoiler I'm not a spoiler I was gonna
walk down the aisle to it did the climb
in Hebrew um it didn't wind up working
out and I was like not gonna be
difficult and what I doing never enough
why we call it I was perfect but that
was an option at one point I was like
everyone would die if it started like
hmm and it's it was it would've been in
Hebrew that would be an epic yeah it
would have been happy but did I have I'm
having flashbacks to summer of 2008 I'd
say how old would I have been there no
younger
2004 mm-hmm seven things I hate about
you
great was my favorite song you know was
also one of my favorite songs that was a
little underrated I don't think it ever
became a single you know song right here
are you overloaded candy-coated your
life's imploding now it's a risk worth
taking a painting worth on this hallowed
ground
we can't let go or is that good and
broken I don't know that was a good song
yeah I'm saying whatever whatever it's
called yeah yeah that whole album where
it's like Miley Cyrus and Hannah Montana
they did a joint partnership so good JP
JP opened up and there was like can't be
tamed album which really was really
great we got Liberty walk we got a cover
of every rose has its thorn but it
started to take her down and every time
[Music]
like every night has it's dawn as well
as thanks Mikey Bruce in my wedding
planner made them for us when we started
working together and they're like
they've lasted a year yeah they're
beautiful just like a the cowboy sings
sad song every rose has your high pitch
is amazing you need to do yeah yeah
that's what it does oh is that Billy Ray
no I don't know who does it on hers but
it's funny anyways it's just an exciting
time that's a story and I hope you
enjoyed this musical medley mm-hmm
next up a little crazy aviation story
Icelandic airline Wow air collapses and
cancels all flights Burnie collapses
Iceland low-cost carrier Wow Air has
cancelled all flights and told
passengers to book with our Airlines
Wow air oh yeah nuts its website has a
travel alert that begins wow air has
ceased operations all Wow air flights
have been canceled the alert said people
who wanted to travel should now look for
so-called rescue fares which may be
offered by rival airlines wow added that
those who made bookings by credit card
or via European travel agency try to get
their money back through those
businesses it said some passengers may
be entitled to compensation from the
airline itself you didn't lose him
people were boarding the plate like they
went we're in the airport and their
airline when
[Laughter]
I think it's actually two planes and
people sitting on the plane when it was
when the airline was cancelled yeah
honestly if you name your airline Wow
air you're asking to not have a long
future yes it was only it started why a
company called Wow air I don't know if
you think of like what other
I guess yeah I would like I would I I
don't find anything that is like I don't
know it's just like a we had such a
weird name I guess I prefer her song
yeah but that was at least Delta that
was the stuff yeah but that was at least
Delta I'm saying oh you like Delta song
yeah I love song it was fun they should
ring it back oh this is good in general
a little pricey yeah but like at least
you you know what you're gonna compare
to other airlines you get what you know
you're getting like you're never gonna
actually might have a deveined version
once in a while
JetBlue needs to fly to more places in
saying that for years
I love JetBlue I don't know if it's in
the cards for them though I think that
they like prefer to be like this me me
like New York to LA lay flat mint get a
popsicle a great name
JetBlue me because like everyone on the
plane needs a mint um anyways I feel
very sorry for everyone who was stranded
like midair or whatever but I personally
have been deveined midair like well I
think the midair ones would would have
finished the flights already had the
fuel and the money and whatever but a
passengers who were like on the tarmac
of in the funny airline that's crazy
like they should have they should have
completed one last flight and one last
hurrah yeah right but I think maybe they
didn't get like their flight plans or I
don't know whatever but also who wants
to be in the air when you know that the
airline doesn't exist anymore it's like
if something happens no one is
accountable no but like the pilot needs
to get a new job so like he needs to
land that plane yeah he needs to fly to
his interview yeah what a weird story
what a weird story I feel like there's
so many weird airline stories these days
an airline I've never heard of that
interesting interesting so rest in peace
where
rest
okay next story it's some exciting news
for stock market live shares lyft is
going public and it's an IPO it is
priced at $72 a stock shorter liftoff in
a highly anticipated initial public
offering lyft shares were price Thursday
afternoon at $72 a piece the top end of
the expected price range honestly that
seems very high considering they send
you five text messages for every time
you book a ride and it's like for that
reason alone I'm out also steps and he
likes like sending me these messages via
the app like we've dropped an offer in
your do you get this no I get [ __ ]
text messages know where my ride is
confirmed when my driver is nearby when
he is arriving when he's in the car and
when I'm done and like I don't want to
text like for that reason I only use
live sparingly however you can connect
it with your Delta SkyMiles and get sky
miles for every time you live and then I
took a lift to the airport you get
double sky miles for an airport ride
well I didn't know that and for that
reason I was back in maybe that's what's
that explains the $70 valuation no but I
get notifications on my phone that just
pop up like we've dropped a coupon in
your app like and then you go there and
it's like 1% off like it's not changing
what I'm doing give me like 10 bucks yes
it you know totally but like this whole
whole ride share uber this whole
industry out of whack prices are through
the roof but I think that's also the
government totally Blasio its de Blasio
these fees have you ever seen of course
you have New York City Taxi Callen
brother in the last month go sit in the
cab it's seven dollars seven dollars a
to dollar and 50 cent fee then there's
all of a sudden a four dollar and 50
cent fee and what's terrible is that
that money goes straight to de Blasio
probably to build a new home and the
taxi drivers get tipped less because
everybody gets into a cab and are like
what the [ __ ] how did it become so
expensive
hanging at your $4 you want to put I'm
gonna drive less but the driver doesn't
get that $4 the medallion doesn't get it
the taxi it goes straight into the
Bosnia's pocket so that we can have more
bumpy roads it's called a congestion tax
and I'm not gonna lie it doesn't make
the city less congested it just makes
everybody poor ya know it's be poor it's
tough out here and I don't it's just a
big issue and I think it's all gonna
come to a head soon because how much
complaining can we do before honestly
like I'm ready to move whenever you guys
want to go tell me when tell me where
I'm there mm-hmm I don't know where it
goes like what about Nashville I was
watching Mary Cavallari and it was very
enticing no it's like a cool place to
visit like what in like the burbs
Nashville we could live on a farm see oh
yeah that's not would be oh my god so
happy his serotonin levels through the
roof hmm it's not really a burbs guy I'm
such a burbs girl
mm-hmm I was like every time I go to the
burbs I'm like okay how many more years
until I can move there mm-hmm
interesting the ride-hailing companies
IPO has excited investors for months
especially in recent days after lyft
increased its share price target range
to between $70 and $72 an increase from
the initial 62 to 68 dollar range in the
land of IPOs in a bull market they are
not incredibly high-priced I think but
that they are fairly priced Brian
Hamilton founder of the financial tech
company staged mergs told cheddar on
Thursday lyft also increased in the
number of shares it sold to thirty two
point five million to thirty point eight
million that seems like a decrease to me
but maybe in shares it's different
anyways all this news and public
companies going public is oh we say
exciting because you know it means that
someone's about to make a shitload of
money whether that's the CEO or whether
it's you because you use Robin Hood for
those who don't know Robin Hood isn't
and I'm not saying you should buy live
shares you know evaluate it for yourself
what do you think in your heart can you
deal with five text messages per ride
we'll talk about that after Robin Hood
is an investing app that lets you buy
and sell stocks ETFs options and Kryptos
all commission-free
kryptos that's where it's actually not
giving stock it's also not worth it I'm
not giving stock tips okay I don't want
to be held accountable while other
brokerages charge up to ten dollars for
every trade Robin Hood doesn't charge
any Commission fees
can trade stocks and keep all of your
profits press there is no account
minimum deposit needed to get started so
you can start investing at any level the
simple intuitive design of Robin Hood
makes investing easy for newcomers and
experts alike view easy to understand
charts and market data and place a
trading just for taps on your smartphone
you can also be used stock collections
such as a hundred most popular with
Robin Hood you can learn how to invest
in the market as you build your
portfolio discover new stocks trade your
favorite companies and get custom
notifications for price movements so you
never miss the right moment to invest
Robin Hood is giving lizard is giving
listeners of the morning toast a free
stock like Apple Ford or sprint to help
you build your portfolio
sign up at toast Robin Hood calm that's
toast Robin Hood calm it is a wonderful
way to start dipping your toe into the
world of stocks which is how people are
making money saying me too I and it's
like I'm not abusive before I'm not some
big like stock savant except now that
I've been watching American greed I feel
like I'm becoming better at learning
like what companies are fraudulent like
I wish actually what's the Elizabeth
Holmes company Sara knows never went
public so you wouldn't have been able to
shorten did you watch my documentary no
I just heard about it it's really good
in there making a movie starring
Jennifer Lawrence so you should watch it
mm-hmm what do you want to say about
just to say back to lift
seems a little pricey I agree nice
saying the last time that everybody was
all brouhaha ooh this is so exciting and
new snapchat it was snapchatting you
know who was up there saying it's
exciting and now who squak Ali except
like she didn't she like she never made
snapchat anything more than it was you
know it was like people who use snapchat
we're like yeah this is cool but it's
like people who didn't use now much I
thought that buying snapchat stock was
gonna like get them a new house here's
the problem we we didn't know enough
about stocks to say that the snapchat
stock would do well we were saying that
it would do well because we liked the
app when in reality the app had no way
of making money so while we liked it
from a user experience first doc to do
oh it needs to make money yeah right
lyft makes money it was right for being
ripped off by Instagram mm-hmm right
right pretty like that word yeah
right season right season reason fifth
and final story little Disney news
Disney fans smoking at us theme parks I
can't believe you could still smoke
honestly that's great
there was nothing sadder than walking up
to a Mickey Mouse and having him reek of
cigs not smoking cigs yeah visitors will
soon no longer be able to smoke at any
of Disney's US parks the company
announced in a blog post on Thursday
it's crazy that like Disney is blogging
starting May 1st Disney will eliminate
all smoking sections from Walt Disney
World Disneyland California's Downtown
Disney in Florida's ESPN Wide World of
Sports Complex in all water parks Disney
said smoking areas will be available
outside the parks entrances so Mickey
could still smoke there if he is you
know an addict quote as we expand our
offerings we will continue to take steps
to enhance the guests experience and
make it more enjoyable for everyone who
visits a Disney spokesperson told CBS
News these cigarettes and vape pens are
included in the band as Disney
spokesperson said I think that's a
little rough it is I think that
e-cigarettes should be allowed deep
means um we right no not necessarily
ok well I think ecigs should be fine
because there's not that second-hand
smoking thing if someone's like ripping
the jewel it's not gonna affect the
person behind them faith is more like a
hookah okay that has like some or it
could be unscented there's a lot of
smoke that comes out yeah I think that's
like what's just like bothersome for
people who don't smoke but a jewel
doesn't affect there is no secondhand
jewel you know no the park also
announced looser dry ice will no longer
be permitted strollers largely and
thirty-one inches wide people bringing
dry ice into Disney World maybe they
were like keeping their lunch cold yeah
what about like having it stick to like
a four year olds foot like that would
really hurt like just randomly like who
like stepped in dry ice hey that's crazy
strollers larger than 31 inches wide and
52 inches long will also not be allowed
we're not the big kid that seems it's
too discriminatory anyways triplet what
about the big kids
what about triplets no just what about
that one big kid like that large happy
boy that's in his big stroller he can't
go to Disney World
that's crazy where it's like that Oh
groans Hodler like that kid in Game of
Thrones who still know everybody's
entitled to their stroller the company
said the reasons behind the change are
to provide a more enjoyable experience
for everyone and reduce congestion
that's oh the congestion tax de Blasio
behind it all or if you wanna have a big
stroller you should pay a tax that's
that's like the equivalent of saying but
larger people should pay more for their
jeans which by the way it's kind of true
it's more fabric
I think it's thought about that like you
having bigger jeans and you have smaller
jeans or paying the same amount for
Jesus yeah we're like it doesn't make
any sense
I think I was looking at dresses or
something like a wedding dress like a
Couture wedding dress where you're
really paying for like the fabric and
you know the it does bedazzled meant
like if you're getting an extra small
versus a large like there's much more
does it call I asked the question like
the source for a bigger size I don't
think that it does
no I'm saying but it costs more to make
yeah it was just curious I don't think
that it should cost more but no it
shouldn't but so really I'm I'm gaming
the system yeah you could I'm getting
more bang for my buck than you I'm
paying in 2018 Disney hiked ticket
prices by up to 18% the cheapest daily
ticket for Walt Disney World and
Disneyland will cost over $100 that's
really crazy like is it $100 for a day
at Disney
but the Disney last so are these people
rockefeller why don't you have a family
of five you stay at a Disney hotel and
they give you like cheaper passes or
they're included can you ever say the
Disney hotel yes like when I went to
Disney when I was very young but I
didn't which one I didn't inquire about
how much our passes work or making sure
I went to the one in Florida so I don't
I think it's Disney World
no but which hotel are you don't
remember so yeah oh no I was a
frequenter if anybody from Disney is
listening here we'd love to go because
you just talk about like Animal Kingdom
know like these days like the adult
Disney fetish that's going on like in LA
where all these like Bachelor people go
to Disney
and now they serve wine so it's like
even more normalized but it's like
literally people from The Bachelor or
like who don't have kids so like I'm not
talking about like I'm in the standing
I'm talking about like scheana is that
Disneyworld like once a week
oh that's well that's a lot of looks
like so weird
mm-hmm but it's just like going to Six
Flags it's just not know but it is
because it's does she live there she
lives in LA so she's going up to Anaheim
it's far yeah like how far it's far to
be going all the time I'm saying is it
is it more than two hours I don't know
because like if you were just like a fan
of roller coasters that's a little weird
who's that okay like that's not a fan of
roller coasters but even if I was I
think once a year would suffice
yeah yeah get my rabies Weiss it's like
[ __ ] yeah I think I could go with
skiing once a year maybe twice yeah yeah
that is strange does she frequents I'm
just I'm not I'm not trying to sing hard
she's the first person that comes to
mind is like someone who's there all the
time and goes I'm kids mhm
Epcot awesome you know what we should
take an adult trip to Disney we're on
how that yeah Disney World is great um
the problem is is that I went with CAUTI
and she just like was not having it she
just didn't want to go anywhere she was
like you went with Claudia for like it
or I tried to go with Claudia no we went
once we were in Orlando there's like
three years ago
we went for a day and she just wasn't
down yeah I don't know we just never got
that bug it's a little bit sadder like
going back like you have all these
memories like little Buzz Lightyear ride
like that's great yeah like yeah that's
kind of sad it's a Epcot is this amazing
Epcot is this amazing place I don't even
remember all of the world's countries in
in one Park the Queen or you could just
go a few blocks away
noise to the UN yeah it's the same thing
same thing same amount of congestion yes
okay without further ado it is the time
of the show where we just ask you
everything everyone wants to know about
you are you ready for that mr. Keane
okay by the way do you like this new
name I've dubbed you the keto King yeah
I like it
oh I thought you would like anymore so
no no it's good it's good it's more I'm
not really the keto King I'm the in the
keto season
keto season yeah speaking of Cato season
make sure to get your keto season
marchek
Kito seton.com this lovely hat is still
available and now there are more men's
options like I actually love this hat mo
trucker you know by the end of the show
I will take out my bread and put it on
because there are a lot of ins sister
there are a lot of lady options there
are there are there are light Purple's
amazing last time I released these often
they were like unisex I thought
everybody would like him but there were
a lot of ladies that were like no this
is my new collection is very plain II I
would say it's nice it's plenty vibes
kedo season weave crop tops tank tops
stickers so yummy head taquito season
calm at the end of the show don't forget
like we will we will remind you so it's
okay if you want um
now on taquito itself because you're
very clear about what kedo season means
to you yes now in the technical
definition of keto are you on keto right
now yes day three day to day one no
seriously it's very very hard it is it's
very hard what are some of the symptoms
that you experienced because I struggle
with like my like what is called the
induction flu sometimes where it's like
I really feel sick and I like get
headaches from the lack of carbs just
when my body's getting used to it so
what are like what are some things that
you experience I've experienced that but
the sheer lack of bread and going to a
restaurant and right there being a bread
basket and going to Serafina and like or
any Italian restaurant and ordering the
fish and not getting a pizza it's just
like life is just like a little bit
sadder in the beginning so if you can
get past a week you feel so good and
that's where keto season came from it's
like holy [ __ ] like I don't have any
headaches I'm less tired like you're
just happy it's very hard so that's why
I go in and out the thing they don't
tell you about is it's a little smelly
apparently for women you get the keto
crotch and for men you just smell all
around there is Devlin keto breath but
something that we have to help you
through this smelly keto journey is
flirt which if you don't know about
Fleur it is a wonderful luxurious
fume product that's all about good clean
organic fun I love organic fun even if
you spritz on perfume every day here's
something you might not think about
what's actually in it that's why I'm so
excited about Fleur
they make stunning non-toxic perfumes
and list all their ingredients online
you get a good scent mean with clean
products and the sample process is just
plain fun so for those of you who are
interested in Fleur it's not only
non-toxic it is also gender free so it's
no like men's and women's I kind of love
that that's cool you know because like
Wabo right it's like I like Zach's
Cologne and his deodorant so maybe I
should be using his Fleur is he like
wearing women's deodorant you know I
actually used was using men's deodorant
work um for a while but I just switch
this week I made the transition to a
natural deodorant you know strong
deodorant I was using really really
strong be owner and then it was barely
working anymore I was like I'm just
becoming too immune to these chemicals I
must go natural which is why I'm using a
natural deodorant and I'm using a
natural perfume mm-hmm Fleur is a
completely transparent fragrance company
they tell you every ingredient in there
perfumes and why it's their go-to Fleur
pH L you are calm today and use promo
code toast to get 20% off your first
custom Fleur sample set pick three cents
to try and get credit towards a
full-size bottle of your favorite that's
promo code toast at Fleur calm to get
your first three Flair fragrance samples
at 20% off pH Lu are.com promo code
toast you guys I highly recommend
honestly a my Kourtney Kardashian I
think so between using a natural perfume
I use natural deodorant I'm just an
all-natural gal mm-hmm honestly I read
an article I don't know if it was last
week or two weeks ago that those like
smelly candles are like doing just as
much to the environment as like gas and
that made me really think like organic
perfume or like organic candles like
that's probably the way to go and like
walking around all day wearing perfume
with like so many chemicals it just
can't be good for you to be breathing
that in all day and it's like I already
feel like [ __ ] all the time so if I can
take these few small steps to feel a
little bit better
when you're in ketosis you feel better
yeah you do yeah I do it's hard for me
to get in ketosis these days also I
don't want it like I don't know how to
tell you this and I don't even think
it's that big of shocking news because I
think I'm pedo season like through and
through well but I've actually been
trying to like get off of keto anything
and just get into like a low calorie
macro diet it's different for a small
lady I don't think you need to be
because I'm also working out and I need
the carbs for energy no you think that
you do the proper energy like oh no I
didn't eat like my trainer said I need
the carbs your trainers wrong try having
a whole lot ekkada okay before you work
out let me know
no seriously it's fun what that I'm not
a trainer no it's fine it's pretty
obvious that I'm not a trainer did we
just get notifications that I yelled to
that oh I have no idea I'm not reading
them I'm looking through the know your
wife is going on Access Hollywood Oh
woo don't tune in tonight no it's
tonight oh it's she's taping it oh I'm
looking through the questions a lot of
people don't know what your job is so
can you please share with the class
yeah it's called securing the bag that's
all but you are boy with a job I'm boy
with a big job can you tell us about
Italy Italy was awesome was it Quito
season it was so Quito season and so not
Quito did you meet the Italian camper I
met an Italian camper I was visiting my
sister
Maddy who was abroad in Florence just
living the life every week just going to
a different country
she was just in Morocco just like
hanging out having a good time she said
was amazing I miss her terribly but he
was a really nice trip and Gucci is so
reasonably priced high reasonably priced
I mean it's so expensive but it's so
much more expensive here so when you get
there you're like oh non-anomalous
please take my money right damn I should
have gotten something you should have I
called you I know I was just like
Claudia was looking for something and I
want to tell you to go to the NAG of
Sylvie's and I just I didn't want to is
that a Gucci bag it's like a sky look at
your accent yeah I know you got the
points damn okay so obviously Claudia
isn't LA to speak like doing mind mental
things you know it's being on Yeley pot
huge leak huge week for her what has
been your proudest moment of being
married to Claudia my proudest moment
this whole year was a very proud moment
she like really just like shucks and
jobs like she doesn't stay down in any
way she just build she keeps building
and building and building and building
and I don't even know what she's doing
like chill just tell me oh by the way
I'm on TV today like wow like like
that's crazy it just does new things
every day and is so driven so yeah I'm
proud of her in that respect
also for forgetting Thea who's my best
friend he's the best boy in the whole
thing the whole
how was he last night I know you were
hanging out with my husband who's known
to be a nothing hater but these days
he's come around he's fine he was fine
human Oh Theo was great how was our that
their dynamic was fine it was fine yeah
my friend teddy was there who really
hates dogs so and like he's afraid of
them so he was there like this so Zach
like seemed like great in comparison to
Teddy who's like which like please he's
licking you looking your foot Oh that'll
be afraid of you no that's great it
would be like being afraid of joy mm-hmm
joy Mangano beautifully when are we
getting that joy on shark tank just
saying oh I know this is a little bit of
old news but what are your thoughts on
Moby J that's Odell Beckham jr. I think
that the Giants are in flux they don't
really know what they're doing and
they're very sad franchise that I
sometimes root for
I need to clear the air people ask me
this all the time what's your favorite
football team I'm a really bad Giants
fan a couple of years ago I was a Jets
fan I occasionally remember Sanchez and
Tim Tebow me too yeah I can only think
about becoming a Raiders fan Las Vegas
seems fun couple years ago I was a
Jaguars fan you should be a Cowboys fan
yeah but that's too much like I really
am a Giants fan at heart so like I can't
read for somebody in the same division
oh that's like being a Knicks and the
nets fan which is like those people
should die but Nixon
give me high fives that's a lyric from
this new mixin Nets give me high fives
true jay-z is a bad fan he is what the
hell is that makes you think that's
weird
how are things going for the next it
depends on what angle you take obviously
the season is a bust but that's fine
the season was meant to be a bust
there's this notion of tanking where the
more games you lose the better chance
you have of getting the top pick in the
draft which is where you select good
college I'm seeing draft day the problem
is that the league changed the rules and
now the top three worst teams all had
the same chance of getting the first
pick so really even if the nicks of the
worst record in the league they still
might not get the first pick so we
really need to pray we have a lot of
money we need to sign some people in the
offseason take Kevin Durant away from
the Golden State Warriors definitely and
and I think we should pick up Chris
Humphries and Danilo Gallinari gone ours
having a great year I mean I could have
predicted that years ago Kris Humphries
is still in the lead
no he's not he's retired and he just
came out with like a blog op-ed in the
players Tribune oh talking about like
his sad life hmm I don't know I hit a
lot of money
justice for [ __ ] Kris Humphries like
it's not even justice you need a lot of
money okay
and he wasn't bad it's like a weird no
but it's like when everything went down
with Kim like he would get booed every
night but you know that happened to
Tristan Thompson every day and like he's
fine he would get booed people knew who
the [ __ ] he was right he was just like
he was getting booed by non basketball
fans and is that his fandom increased
tenfold that's true
like Boozer who's a good thing in sports
this is a great question for you if you
were on death row what would your last
meal be Wow sushi come on Jackie
no ishikawa Nishikawa 74th first and
second greatest it's not where they went
billions where he like no it's where
it's only me only I know about it really
I think they might have won ther
billions to watch millions no great job
unbelieva what kind of role like
what Oh Makka say yeah but like that
sounds douchey so like you can just like
get pieces they have this it's called
five finger Toro where you need to pick
it up with five fingers holy cow and the
chef chef Dom just after like five
pieces will open my mouth and pour in
spicy mayo as like a palate cleanser
we have like a really great rapport and
yeah well Claudia's away me and chef Tom
have you been to Bond Street yeah like
in 2012 I went there last week and I had
last week horrible meal of my life okay
don't act like it's only Nina Agdal was
there yeah I mean the food was atrocious
and I didn't even order anything crazy I
got a spicy tuna roll and like it was
never like you would think it's sushi is
only bad when the fish is bad believe
that was like their rice had like so
much sesame seeds and poppy noni and it
wasn't good I got the the tuna tartare
and it was like the lethal one where
it's like premium every bite it's like a
bite of gold and like it was so waxy and
disgusting everything was horrible so
I've actually heard I feel like people
come to New York and they think Bond
Street is one of those places that you
need to go if you're interested in
seeing Nina Agdal you should go
otherwise don't go for the food
apparently their meat is really good
when I used to go when when Claudia ate
meat and she would get the steak and it
was apparently like really really
fantastic but to quickly interject I
have a funny story speaking of
restaurants that we may or may not like
talk poorly about I was photographing my
pastrami the other night and people
seemed to be confused like Oh what is
that like it's pastrami like where do
you live that you don't know what
pastrami looks like and somebody
messaged me what do you think of Sarge's
deli and I wrote back it sucks and the
reason why it sucks is because it's a
non kosher deli which that's just like
sacrilegious like if you're serving
pastrami it needs to be closed from
mommy auntie Rebecca oh I own it and
that was a tough conversation you know
no but I then clarified oh my god I love
it like your locks is great I think
that's it no like I just can't eat it
like it make your deli make your kosher
style deli kosher yeah never understood
that kosher style yeah that's not a
thing
no it's not a thing it's other kosher in
our culture no kosher style
so uh we have a question for you a very
interesting maybe a piece of part of you
I that I don't know about the sleeve
wiley loves when Ben talks about his
faith his passion really shows mm-hmm
any faith-based readings or podcasts
you've come across with that have
impacted you any faith-based readings
where am i Joel Olsteen actually in
Psalm 34 this week no I mean listen to
any podcast no no no the morning shows
that's hurtful morning toast no I don't
I don't have but I don't have time
because I don't have a commute I'm
fortunate enough that I walk to my big
job in securing the bag and it's like a
ten minute walk so I don't have time for
a large podcast and people who listen to
podcasts during the day that have that
option it's it's great I don't I don't
have that I understand um but no my my
relationship with with God or as I call
him Hashem is is a very personal one I
am definitely very spiritual and and
talked to him or her or it all day long
you know I don't I don't have a specific
reading or DVAR Torah as they say for
this one well you should have been
prepared I should have been prepared for
that for that question
Wow okay sweet converse sheets imagine
if I just came with it but it's not
Bracy
no it's not what are we am probably
bumming bar huh we're in the desert
iron Leo ways right in time for
Coachella and stagecoach last question
before I let you go it's Robin what's
the ultimate keto season meal sushi the
same exact place that I said Oh world
maketo meal is that the question Romeo
yell to me is the happens week you know
season yes on keto diet yeah say say say
yes but I'm saying that's not keto
season it could be tuna tartare get
yourself some good tuna tartare that is
very keto and keto season get yourself
some burrata
mmm make sure that it's not too
on the outside because then that's like
a big bowl of mozzarella and that's not
burrata Oh in Italy I had this pirata in
Italy in Florence they have a you know
how the middle of the burrata is like
the creamy delicious part they don't
have the outside they just put it in
like a little bathtub and you just drink
it like a soup and then literally you
have enough gas to power your way back
to the States
like with no plane that is nice burrata
mat and steak steak is I don't really
believe seasoned and delicious but if
you're not pat then you also need to
like the only downside is that you need
to be aware of how much red meat you're
having and like you're not all the time
for sure yeah a Dover sole is great a
branzino a striped bass a cognizant a /
cogsa sometimes I thought for all of
those non kosher folks maybe a shrimp
cocktail it mussels oh my gosh if I was
not sure I would be the skinniest [ __ ]
on the clams and linguine the claims
casino anyways thank you for joining us
before we let you go keno season comm
for new merch we will be back on Monday
with Claudia in the meantime feel free
to follow me I track your problems
because you know I worked really hard
for all you guys this week and it's like
the least you can do um thank you bunch
I thought I had like one more thing to
ask you about but I guess that's it
thank you for having me
let's go have lunch a very keto lunch
yes please and you can follow me at big
soft it's a little sad over there it is
you don't post premium content and I
tried to tell you I thought semi premium
content I'm not really great thank you
something and asked you to preset it for
me and you didn't respond because I had
a migraine so you can't preset no I
can't look at my phone fine
I think I said okay I'll talk to you
later not like ignored
I think big soft boy with no job if
you'd like to follow me and you don't do
ready I'm sure that you do well is it a
job is premium and the stories are
premium a big stop it's like you take a
video of your friend Victor you post it
to your story and you post it on
Instagram like
not a premium strategy I need a new
strategy for big song you honestly you
need to work with the same agency that
Theo's working with because his [ __ ] is
premium Co agency vo it oh my god oh my
god oh my god that's great that was like
when I was doing nothing use weekend out
with him and we were watching COC all
weekend Co agency vo show oh the Oh
remember the O show the osteen the old
steam Jackie Jackie Olsteen that's
incredible anyways thank you all for
tuning in this week bearing with us
through our very diverse set of guests
with different opinions and
personalities honestly I thoroughly
enjoyed it kept me on my feet and to end
with Ben what could be more enjoyable so
have a great weekend make sure to follow
us subscribe etc Alita burger of you
leave a comment whatever you feel like
doing and just have a great weekend have
so much fun we're gonna have fun at
Ben's birthday party and we'll see you
on camera sees later kitty Susan calm
the hosel Turner COO recording back home